l' empire alain vient d'y faire allusion
l'allemagne fédérale avait elle aussi
réclamé l'extradition de klaus barbie
alors pourquoi l' expulsion at-elle été
décidée vers la france il s'agit peut
être là d'un accord politique entre les
deux pays
une correspondance de michel meyer à
bonn qui nous relate d'abord les
réactions de la presse et la manière
dont a été présenté l'événement barbie
c'était en début de soirée hier le
deuxième titre de l'actualité télévisée
mais dans les dernières éditions des
journaux télévisés l'expulsion en france
du bourreau de lyon était passé en
première place largement on explique à
ses culpabilité et ont mis en
perspective l'action de la justice
française pour un co inc s correspondant
de la télé allemande à paris le futur
procès barbie aura une signification
historique
il montrera ce dont est capable un
système totalitaire par ailleurs très
rapidement une allusion réaction du
gouvernement de bonn la mention qu'une
demande d'extradition avait aussi été
formulée par la rfa dans la presse
écrite gros titre en première page ce
matin des articles qui aurait pu être
écrit à paris ou à lyon les crimes de
barbie sont énumérées ces complicités
bolivienne et néo nazis révélée sans
complaisance le bourreau de lyon titre
le bilan de son attaque
une façon d'exprimer à la fois distant
et malaise envers barbie au niveau des
autorités politiques et malgré le fait
que l'extradition de klaus barbie avait
été demandée par l'allemagne fédérale
auprès de la bolivie
on peut parler ici d'un certain
soulagement en effet on considère ici
que si barbie avait été extradé en
allemagne fédérale
il aurait bénéficié comme tout un chacun
des libéralités d'une justice allemande
qui on ne répétera pas assez depuis 1949
par exemple ne connaît plus la peine de
mort le fait que ce jugement n'aurait
pas forcément été acceptée à l'étranger
notamment en france ont été une occasion
de relance d'un certain nombre de
tensions et d'animosité de ressentiment
de part et d'autre du rhin et cela les
autorités allemandes n'en voulait pas en
outre 40 ans après un crime tout
jugement reste une mission très
difficile pour n'importe quel tribunal
je crois que dans cette affaire on a
donc préféré laisser cette mission
un tribunal français il y allait de la
crédibilité et de la vérité de ce
jugement
et cette priorité à un tribunal français
a été laissé
d'après mes informations très précises
après une concertation très étroite au
plus haut niveau entre paris et bonn
alors pour être un conte